congrats
seriously first two episodes are
fantastic um
so a bunch of questions uh watching the
episodes made me think
how much free will do people have in the
mcu
because you could make an argument that
the time
uh keepers are sort of manipulating
everything
yeah absolutely that's i think i think
that's
i think that's part of what's so
interesting about this thing moving
forward is like wait holy [ __ ]
was this with these guys pulling the
strings of everything
uh i think it's a fair question to ask
what can you say about sophia's
character
nothing uh i'm excited i think like you
um it's it's a really exciting end to
episode two
and and i think i'm excited for
everybody to see what happens next
uh yeah i want to dig in but i'll leave
it alone uh was the series always going
to start
at avengers tower in 2012 or did you
ever have another version no that was
always where we wanted it to start
um yeah fortunately in game gave us our
our opening scene and and so
uh we knew we wanted to just really pick
our story
up right as loki you know what what
happened on the other end of that that
uh space stone hole how many people
actually work at the tva do you know
i mean i you know probably the best way
to answer that is just
think about the amount of work that has
to be done
there cataloging all of time
running pretty much consecutively at
all times how many people would that
take
uh you know loki he looks out that
window and he sees
the enormity of it so uh
yeah it is a it is a large-scale
operation we see as the audience
uh humans working at the tva are there a
lot of other races
i mean like you guys discuss this
we discussed it i mean everything we're
showing you is
is deliberate so you know we will
you know what what you're seeing you're
seeing for a reason
so i i think you know if if we're going
to see other people
maybe we will maybe we won't i
understand
uh how much of the backstory of the
timekeepers and how they
came into existence did you guys figure
out
the timekeepers i mean that that was a
case of a really cool thing in the
comics
that you know the timekeepers have a lot
of lore there
and we were able to pull from that and
uh you know take what was exciting about
their mythology and everything
and then i was able to build in you know
kind of our own
uh crazy ideas that fit within the world
of our own shows it was a kind of a
fusion of
of who they are in the comics and and
perhaps who they are
in our world what can you say about the
stones that are on their head on the
timekeeper's head
yeah you gotta wait and see
oh you're like you're like if the fans
are like loki they just wanna they want
an audience with those timekeepers
yeah listen i'm watching the episodes i
took notes i'm trying to you know
trying to you know dig in um and maybe
this will be explained in the series but
with can the timekeepers did you guys
figure out can they be killed
are they gods are they you know did you
have to figure all that stuff
out there was certainly a we we had to
really define for ourselves who are the
time keepers
right like like who you know who are
these characters that you're gonna put
on the show you're going to take them
seriously
as real entities and as clearly
incredibly powerful entities within the
world of the mcu
so uh yeah i mean all of that
investigation of who they are and and
and what their
uh rules are was all stuff we had to
figure out and define
there's almost a throwaway line in
episode one about the multiverse
war but it's there uh can you sort of
talk about
that because it seems to me like this
series is
definitely opening the door onto what
could be happening in
doctor strange and spiderman
everything's there for a reason
you know and and and i think look the
tva
if we take them at their word they're
they're making a pretty good point
they're trying to prevent
something terrible a multiversal war
sounds fairly awful
so uh that's that's what they're trying
to do they're trying to keep loki from
from causing more chaos and everything
so you know the implications of that
as far as the rest of the mcu goes are
certainly interesting
how old do you think mobius is
gosh that's that's a great a great
question i
i think as he says to loki time passes
different
at the tva i'm not even sure mobius
knows how old he is i think that these
guys working at the tva
they perceive and experience time in a
totally different way
uh than you and i it's it's non-linear
they're living
outside of it and so therefore it's just
he doesn't really think of himself in
terms of
old or young are there easter eggs in
the series that people should be
looking out for any scenes particularly
that you might recommend hitting pause
i think folks should definitely uh
should always be on the lookout um
i think every scene is worth hitting
pause if nothing else just because of
how
beautiful the sets are and the lighting
and everything just just how remarkable
it all looks and
you never know what you might find uh as
you're
as you're screen grabbing uh there was
an image that uh someone pointed out
online this morning about uh
a screen grab i think even that says uh
loki's
um sex is fluid um uh
can you talk about that aspect and was
that a debate
or was that sort of like we're doing
this no i mean that
that was yeah i i i saw that this
morning i mean that's
i think that's canon for the for this
character going back to norse mythology
and everything
that's an important part of uh who
this character is and and certainly you
know who he represents is
such a large part of the fan base and
everything so
never a debate on that at all uh
talk a little bit if you don't mind the
device that the timekeepers use of
resetting the timeline
can you sort of explain that to um can
you sort of explain the device
yeah it's it's uh it's called a reset
charge
um and and basically what it's doing is
taking
a branch that has uh veered off
its set path and it's uh
it's resetting it um through
uh through through what means magic
perhaps or or perhaps something a little
more technical
uh you know i i think like loki
we're kind of in the dark of like what's
what exactly is going on
with these reset charges uh you know
is the tva as uh as noble as they're
presenting themselves to be
uh was uh hunter b-15 originally written
as a black one
100 b15 was kind of written as a we just
knew there was going to be an
adversarial
character for for loki
um there was once upon a time a
character that
that ultimately we couldn't clear
because of rights
or something and and then it was like we
knew
we wanted to cast a really strong
diverse
actress there and and so you know
me is amazing and i think it's
particularly cool that
loki finds himself under the thumb of
two very strong black women in this show
and and have you actually pitched
marvel on an idea for loki season two
or do you view season one as i hit the
home run i did it
i'm good let me go do other things
i don't know we'll we'll see if it's uh
let's i'm not even out of the batters
box on uh on on season one right now
so uh let's let's let's just see if
kevin feige will still take my calls
uh at the end of all this i'm i'm sure
he will
again this will this will be my last
question um
obviously there is never enough time and
never enough budget
to do everything you want to do what was
the big thing that you sort of came up
against
in making loki that you had to overcome
honestly our imaginations were not
capped one bit that's a testament to
marvel
uh to the brilliant creative producers
kevin wright
stephen broussard who really steered us
told us you know shoot for the moon
and then how kate shot the show she she
you know everything we put on the page
she found a way to not only
render but elevate make it even cooler
so
uh our our biggest challenges were we're
making sure that
you know it's a time travel show so it's
let's let's make sure that folks aren't
getting bored or bogged down
in the uh in the time travel exposition
and everything they can just have fun
and go along for the ride on that note
gotta go i'm just gonna say again
congrats can't wait to see more
thanks man good to see you